ich möchte millionen menschen sehen die
im weltraum arbeiten und dort leben das
sind die worte von jeff bezos dem
gründer von amazon und blue origin blue
origin dass private us raumfahrt
unternehmen das viele verschiedene
krasse visionen verfolgt um den weltraum
endgültig zu erobern die neuesten
einblicke dazu gab es jetzt auf einer
konferenz in los angeles
was plant messers und wie weit ist der
mit seinen entwicklung und er hat einen
revolutionären plan der unsere
zivilisation verändern könnte klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
blue origin liefert sich unter anderem
mit virgin galactic schon seit längerer
zeit ein spannendes kopf-an-kopf-rennen
darum wer als erstes touristen in den
weltraum schicken kann und dafür
investiert der gründer jeff bezos viel
sehr viel sogar es gibt anekdoten nach
denen der blue origin durch den verkauf
von amazon aktien finanziert und das mit
einer milliarde dollar pro jahr anders
als virgin galactic tüfteln die macher
von blue origin an einer art raumkapsel
die durch die news shepherd rakete
angetrieben wird in 100 kilometern höhe
wird die kapsel abgetrennt und schwebt
dann zur erde
möglich machen das fallschirm senkrecht
also ohne erdumrundungen und dann in der
kapsel am fallschirm hängend wieder
zurück damit ließen sich einige minuten
schwerelosigkeit erleben einen konkreten
preis nennt besser nicht doch wir haben
ja vor kurzem berichtet schätzungen
zufolge dürften die gibt nicht mehr als
50.000 dollar kosten und diese kapsel
soll tatsächlich noch in diesem jahr zum
ersten mal ab ins weltall fliegen und
zwar bemannt im moment ist sie schon
mehrmals geflogen und besseres hat mit
den testflügen bereits bewiesen dass
seine vision umsetzbar sind die
touristen raketen shepherd ist schon
fünf geflogen und auch wieder sicher auf
die erde zurückgekehrt und jeffers ist
von seiner vision mehr als überzeugt er
ist der mann der es geschafft hat amazon
als größten onlinehändler der welt
aufzubauen und auch von der
konkurrenzfähigkeit seiner raketen ist
er mehr als überzeugt teilweise ist
bessers meinung über die raumfahrt und
ihre zukunft zu vergleichen mit den
ansichten von ihnen maske beide wollen
raketen wieder verwendbar machen so die
raumfahrt zu einer art low cost produkt
machen konkret von raketen demnächst wie
heutzutage flugzeuge nur kurz
zwischenlanden um inspiziert und
aufgetankt zu werden dann könnten sie so
die vision gleich wieder losfliegen
doch einen unterschied gibt es schon
zwischen den beiden ländern besser suite
sehr geplant und langsam schritt für
schritt vor zunächst einmal die
kleineren wiederverwendbaren raketen
dieses besseres 900 kilometer hoch
bringen sollen dann ist die größere geht
die new gm in den startlöchern
sie ist je nach version bis zu 95 meter
hoch also höher als max rakete falcon
heavy nach besser planen könnte sie 45
tonnen in eine niedrige umlaufbahn
schicken immerhin 13 tonnen in eine
geostationäre um noch fahren das ist
mehr nutzlast als die europäische rakete
ariane
sechs transportieren kann und es gibt
bereits kunden die an dem start der new
zealand im jahr 2020 interesse
angemeldet haben aber auch bemannte und
unbemannte kapseln können sie sie
transportieren egal ob richtung mars
oder mond die triebwerke der großen
neuen jänner geht sind sieben schuf
starke triebwerke die mit unterstützung
der nasa entwickelt werden damit
erhoffen sich die amerikaner unabhängig
von den russischen triebwerken zu werden
die bislang die amerikanischen atlas
raketen antreiben danach könnte dann das
projekt blue moon realisiert werden
dabei geht es um eine lieferanten kapsel
mit der man den mond besiedeln könnte
mit dem lande system für den mond sollen
bis zu viereinhalb tonnen fracht auf den
mond gebracht werden und dazu äußerte
sich jetzt chef clauses auf der weltraum
entwickler konferenz ende mai in los
angeles
es ist zeit auf den mond zurückzukehren
und auch dort zu bleiben
sein wunsch sturm mit hilfe von esa und
nasa oder eben einer anderen staatlichen
weltraumbehörde eine permanente mond
siedlung zu erbauen
doch im fall der fälle sei er auch
bereit seine pläne alleine in die tat
umzusetzen abgesehen davon träumt er
außerdem von einer revolutionären idee
industrieanlagen im weltall
diese könnten 24 stunden am tag durch
sonnenenergie angetrieben werden
umweltverschmutzung und alle anderen
folgen wären von der erde verbannt
rohstoffe aus dem all könnten genutzt
werden und und und der absolute wahnsinn
besser spricht in diesem zusammenhang
von einem zeitraum von jahrzehnten in
denen genau das umgesetzt werden kann
wenn ihr kein video zu den zukünftigen
weltraum pläne und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei what's up dann umgeht er die kaputte
abo box hier auf youtube und verpasst
kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich und garantiert einfach
hier draufklicken und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal klicks zum social
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier
kriegen wir aber nicht die genau die
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken neues
zeitalter der raumfahrt eingeleitet
neuer space ex rekord bis dann bleibt
dran